good game oh hey guys you guys know that
for five years gamespot's the marathon
streaming games for the kids that's
right we're back at it again this year
this Friday November 11 sat noon
marathon streaming 72 hours to benefit
UCSF Children's Hospital in Oakland
California you guys aren't going to want
to miss it we're all gonna be there I'm
gonna be there my best friend's you're
gonna be there Rob your will be there
Mary I am totally gonna be there tell me
more you know I also heard that not just
72 hours of awesome quality streaming
content but it's gonna span across three
different continents how many that's
three I know so it's gonna kick off
friday with our SF headquarters office
you'll be there I'll be there a lot of
other people will be there and then it's
going to shift condens we're gonna take
over to the UK office that's correct and
they're gonna Bend London and they're
gonna go for about 12 more hours that's
so crazy and then it's going to ship
right back over here for us once again
and we're gonna go for 24 hours that's a
long time I might be completely looped
out you know what I mean I lose your
mind all flustered and everything and
then after that we're not done yet it's
gonna get tossed oh but we're gonna
throw that ball all the way over to
australia sydney sydney precisely where
our other offices there and they're
gonna finish the whole shebang let's sum
up all those hours how many hours is
that 12 whoa 24 24 24 72 hours for the
children this is all going to charity
every penny earned so you guys are not
going to want to miss it he's going to
be streamed on camp spot twitch you
tube you name it the stream they're
probably gonna do it you know very well
organized yeah all of it mostly twitch
and we will see you guys there this
Friday November 11th at noon thanks see
you guys get one kiss picking kids